terence davis on the floor
another rebound ball number nine all
behind
that pad
[Applause]
wow that's a little flare look at that
pass right on the money in stride
[Applause]
paul protects leaves it for bid
to miles and again nothing's happening
okay i'm going to drive
draw kick biz you finish it play above
the right and a steal
wonderful anticipation but the ball gets
taken away from luvello
mamello ahead of the pack he's got
mcdaniel
[Applause]
he's got a high flyer running with him
with the pass in the left hand
lamella quickly the other way and now
the hornets will set up shop
[Applause]
look at this dell look at that look away
right
[Applause]
boy i was gonna have fun playing with
him all year
folks in charlotte should be very
excited about we're going to see lamelo
ball right now jeffy checked in during
the timeout wearing number two for
charlotte
b.j washington from ball getting all of
the loose balls are getting out and
getting easy buckets in transition a lot
of great hustle plays being made
washington gets three back
this group on the floor doing the
majority of that
here's paul on the lab for bridges
paul has a great feel for the game
doesn't he the first two games against
tirana he's knocked down four tonight
cole anthony
has it taken away ball on the lob
and reaching way back as miles bridges
unable to convert the three-point play
but the lead is down to eight
canelo ball corner three
rozier good again
terry rose very many slam dunk
championships in his career
[Applause]
basketball is strong david the truck
just buzzed an entire country
no they bust you david it was you
zeller for three got it cody zeller
111-107
a three-point shot rattles in malik monk
pulling on to pulling for these
teammates here in the closing minutes
james springer trying to work out what's
up guys as well
what a pass by ball leading monk
beautifully down the open floor
lamelo ball with the one-handed bounce
pass
on the money to monk charlotte's up by
four
first year in cleveland three times a
champion all of recent vintage
won twice in golden state last year
playing for the lakers
oh all around good shot gordon hayward
hits his first three miles bridges into
the game
bismarck biambo as well hayward
got it and the hornets all of a sudden
finding their shooting shoes
[Applause]
lamelo thought about it now even
strength
pj got it
everything that happened since march in
the with the nba
taking some time off really helped his
recovery and his rehab and
he he's able to take his time gordon
hayward
miles made four straight threes taylor
ended the game last night
irving upset didn't get the call oh
goodness here
how do you do
cesaret coming he's those are going to
have resistance
punch it through young fella
[Applause]
wow in his spare time he puts together
computers
you won't have a lot of space oh my
hail's branches
he had to look back to make sure that
stayed down and the hustle
this pass right here
hornet's going really young everyone on
the floor is a three-year pro
or less miles bridges another southpaw
sling
his third three of the quarter
[Applause]
with a left hand and he's fouled
confess look at this finish little slip
pass oh
one power move biz with a nice left hand
[Applause]
put it right on top of cauli style one
of the best shot blockers in the game
lamello working the baseline old school
steve
nash
[Applause]
memphis gives back two as bismarck
biambo crawls it over the rim his head's
on a swivel
[Applause]
pj a beautiful fine lamella hit him
and pj's now let's get aggressive look
at this right here
good delivery how about that right on
point
lamella keeps the dribble alive leaves
it for biz
two hands
mellow here ken with the spin and then
sees valentinos with his
hands down trying to stop the ball lays
it right over the biz and easy two hands
wanted to hit their last five shots
miles the quick spin oh man took it
right to mcdermott well
credit lamellar ball for that seeing
that mismatch he
weighed rozier out miles bridges has
been quiet
just one for four shooting the
basketball
caleb martina got it that's a long two
second time today dell he's had a toe on
the line
[Applause]
it starts with lamello
design play for rozier and he
capitalizes that's good coaching you got
a hot guy you need to score points
curry working off of embiid long rebound
lamello looks ahead two on one
miles bridges
long pass long rebound right here and
[Applause]
ten point first half for seth curry
bismarck puts mb right in the basket for
that
and then lamelo quickly to
comes off a game yesterday when he was
struggling just six points one of eleven
shooting
after the timeout score it at a foul
chance for a four point play perfectly
timed
let his pass over the shoulder by
lamella right
in rhythm to rozier danny green clips
him
that added on to a championship that he
won as a tar heel
that's that's good gm we're all off the
window you deserve that terry rogers
[Music]
[Applause]
look at this play right here tobias
harris thinks he's got it covered
over to pj
good luck for devonta maybe a little
confidence
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
behind the defense harris couldn't tap
it home
[Applause]
[Applause]
bianco and hayward
[Music]
devonte fourth point of the game
that's a good play devante screens the
screener of the day off tomorrow game
against atlanta on wednesday
payoff on thursday game against new
orleans on friday
dwight howard passes it off the shin of
ben simmons
strong hands by hayward you keep
possession of the basketball
see angles they have to take
anticipation
learn the game learn what the other
teams the schemes are offensively so you
can see the play before it happens
lamela ball all of 180 pounds
hayward already hit a pair give him
three
closing in the halfway mark of our
second quarter
devante grant back in for the hornets
along with terry rozier
and pj washington two more for hayward
this guy right here the ball is a good
one
rozier so was that guy all wet
two in a row for terry
wanted to have lost three consecutive
games memphis and twice against philly
p.j washington hornets have now hit
three consecutive triples drive it
throw it right back right on the money
2-5 you're open line it up and knock it
down
[Music]
and williamson turns it over lamella
ball with the pick and the nice feed in
transition
to terry rozier for two he did a great
job of hitting alexander walker
as we see the turnover there by
williamson playing in traffic
that turns into the transition but
getting back to ingram
that's where his improvement has been
the best part
is his three-point shooting game a
beautiful pass
by ball to biambo if you're the older
brother guarding the younger brother
there should be no flagrant fouls you
should be able to do whatever you want
to him
[Applause]
would you have been okay with that
considering stan's two years older than
you
he's not even getting interviewed right
tonight like at the end of the first
because they're the home team
right so he's got to wait till the third
quarter we'll see what the score is
there wow miles bridges
absolutely abuses the rim five years
with orlando and three with miami
that is some dunk right there late
rotation by heart
brother lanza was out there but they're
not guarding one another lonzo was
supposed to be guarding rozier there
and rozier knocks down his second three
of the half
lamelo rookie third overall 19 years old
lonzo in his fourth season 23 years old
lamela with a nice fine the three is
good from bridges and it's a three-point
game
you guys said you want to go to lunch i
said no you you guys go right ahead
continue your country that's why we
needed the van gundy podcast
graham trying to shake alexander walker
timers at three here's ball with a kick
out
rozier drains the three and there's the
eighth assist for ball
had much higher expectations coming out
because he played at ucla and obviously
was the first ball brother
and lavar was such a bigger story then
we don't hear from him as much now
that was lamela with a great pass and
the three by hayward